d guess he doesn't need really an
introduction especially at this kind of
workshop he's one of the one of the you
know the main drivers and organizers of
the the latus program here obviously one
of the pioneers of the mathematics
underlying likes photography and lattice
face cryptography itself so it's a great
pleasure that Daniela here and for the
first connection between sis ok thank
you for the introduction and inviting me
here so for a moment when you said that
I didn't need an introduction I thought
you were about to say this is the third
talk I'm giving in this semester and
yeah anyway so just to make it your very
eyes so this time I will give a
whiteboard talk yeah so I can also draw
slides so you can watch the videos but I
think then the slides are limited them
for today
so this will work out well and also so a
point about this issue of a crypt
analysis is not being rewarding I would
like to add a few data clarification
[ __ ] analysis is quite rewarding I mean
when you try to break something and you
break it
oh that's very rewarding so that their
level of you know it's really
sensational ok and you get your you know
best paper award or the admiration of
the community the really tricky part is
when you try to criminalize something
which is secure and your effort doesn't
quite produce the crypt analysis and I
think it is quite an issue right now for
especially for quantum post quantum
cryptography one of the questions that I
get more often from people outside the
dis community is how do we know that
lattice cryptography is secure even
against quantum computers because you
know I searched around I couldn't find
any single paper show in a quantum
attacks that you lattice crypto so it
sounds like nobody's even trying to do
it so the problem is that I think we do
need a way to somehow document this
effort that I know personally from
talking to people that people have been
trying to pull
to analyze that tack and see if it's
something can be done so even when it
doesn't quite work with it the break it
would be useful to find a way to have a
record of of these things but anyway so
this is more of an aside for everybody
to think about if anybody is a good
suggestion or idea in this could also be
a great opportunity great place to
discuss to discuss that let's get to the
matter of mine Tolkien we're talking
about a number of things and let me
first make a list of all the various
names and buzzwords and problems that
will be mentioned in my talk so I'll
start with the two central problems in
lattice used in lattice cryptography
which are the S is a short integer
solution problem and the lwe problem or
learning with errors
so so these are the two pros are to
average case problems problems where you
are picking a lattice at random and the
corresponding lattice problem is solve
is a conjecture to be hard and on one
side it is possible to give some
evidence about the harness of these
problems by connecting them with certain
other lattice problems that are more
commonly studied and used outside of
cryptography and we'll see many of them
there is a long list of problems that I
will mention but there are two main so
among these we have that gap as VP the
gap a shortest vector problem the
shortest independent vector problem
bounded distance decoding then there's a
problem that for a lack of a better name
some people called a DDI the absolute
distance decoding the shortest vector
problem has VP CVP and more and more and
so on and so on and so on I will define
the main problems in this list don't
worry about the other long list of names
but the main difference between these
problems and those two is that the two
problems up there are average case
problems are problems with a probability
distribution on instances so these are
standard complexity or algorithms
problems that you want to solve in the
worst case and so an algorithm lets of
this problem is an algorithm that given
any instances no matter how it was
chosen and tries to produce a solution
and one of the most remarkable features
of lattice cryptography and what brought
lot of attention to these to these
problems is that it is possible to
connect these two classes of problems if
you can break those problems on average
then you can design algorithms for this
problems that are remark on
only studied in complexity theory and
algorithms so in the other on the
opposite side we also have cryptographic
applications so think of this as the
foundation of the lattice cryptography
problems which are these two and on the
application side that you can build a
pretty much everything however the type
of so the first one is a yes leads it to
a much smaller class of problems from si
yes it is possible to build the
symmetric key encryption functions
digital signature sir
commitments and a few more things and so
while digital signatures is typically
considered a public key primitive I mean
there's a public key in a digital
signature scheme all these things that
they fall in a class that we can think
morally has been a private key so
digital signatures is something that can
be built out of any one-way functions so
it's not something it's not something
that requires the type of structure that
is used in public key cryptography so
lwe gives a much broader class of
applications so starting from a public
key encryption all the way to anything
you want so one of the most complex
applications of lwe is SHG fully
homomorphic encryption which are skins
that allowed to perform computations on
encrypted data and so you can think of
these as some kind of creep tapia where
you can do everything you want and there
is a way to do it so my talk today will
be centered around the connection
between these two problems what would do
the heaven common what says them apart
and how to relay how do they relate with
the worst case problems and we're
interesting the quantum somehow seems to
be key to understanding the relation
between these two problems and so this
is something that four people have been
working on the complexity of lattice
problems is a well-known but perhaps
will be interesting for some of you to
see how the quantum comes up in the
study of the complexity of the problems
and there are some very interesting
questions there so does this work
oh is it yeah okay well that was working
too bad I didn't take they all little
white bird okay
so let me start by briefly introduce in
the these problems the lattice problems
which I think are the best way to
understand to understand what's really
going on here so most of you probably
already are already familiar with
lattices know what a lattice is but just
for concreteness so a lattice is a set
of points in a Euclidean space so
geometrically you can think of it as the
set of intersection points of an
n-dimensional grid and algebraically you
can describe it as the set of all
integers combinations of a collection of
basis vectors so you
a key matrix B that we can assume for
simplicity is a non singular square and
by n matrix a base for ryuk linear space
for RN and instead of taking the entire
linear span of B which would be our end
we only take the combinations of these
basis vectors with integer coefficients
which gives as a result a discrete set
of points okay so this seems a very
simple object it is interesting
especially in cryptography when you
consider these objects for in a larger
dimensions in a two dimension there is
not really much cryptography you can do
with in two dimension with lattices
everything is easily solvable in
polynomial time in fact it is
irresolvable but just by looking at the
picture and so what are so T so I will
illustrate the problems in two
dimensions and you can try to imagine
how it works in n dimensions so the
classic problems on lattices are SVP the
shortest vector problem
do this and any put that is that this is
going to be a list of problems solid
we'll use that for a draw in here we can
start listing the problems the shortest
vector problem and so one of these
points is say the origin and the shorter
spirit or problem asks so given a
lattice represented by a basis should be
and you find a lattice point there is as
short as possible so you can think of
putting a ball around the origin that is
as small as possible and you want a non
zero vector in it another classic
problem is the closest vector problem
where you are given and not only basis B
but you're also given a target vector T
and the question is to find a lattice
point is closest to the target so you
want to minimize the distance of death
so it is the target T you put ball
around the target you want to find
something at various close to the target
now so these are the two central most
studied problems in lattice algorithms
and complexity and somehow surprisingly
we don't know how to build cryptography
out of these two so the project which
are used to build cryptographic
functions are not the SVP or CVB
problems so the problems that come up in
cryptography are some restricted
versions of the closest vector problem
that can be described as follows one is
the bounded distance decoding problem
and in the bounded distance they got in
problem you look at the general
properties of the lattices so the
lattice can have a certain geometric
structure and important value so that
characterized the geometry of the
lattice are the minimum distance between
the two lattice points so this is a
discrete sector so that there will not
be points arbitrarily close to each
other you can look at how close came to
such point B and if you take a ball of
radius 1/2 this minimum distance these
balls will be all disjoint so you can
call these the radius of these disjoint
balls so this called the packing radius
of the lattice
and it equals exactly half the length of
the shortest vector so lambda 1 is the
mathematical symbol typically used to
describe the length of disrespect or
half of lambda 1 is this packing radius
and BDD is a special version of the
closest vector problem where the target
is assumed to be
we've been these packing radius so think
of it as closes vector problem where the
target is close to the lattice it is the
so close that the solution is unique
just by construction they will be at
most one point within distance R from
the target so the other problem that
comes up in lattice cryptography is the
absolute distance decoding if you had a
better suggestion for the name feel free
to suggest it so this is something that
so I first recall the guaranteed
business decoding and then so this is
another name that came up I'm still not
quite happy with either name but is the
idea so you can make this balls bigger
than the packing register right now
there are certain points which do not
belong to any ball so they are outside
so you can keep increasing the size of
these balls until they cover the entire
space and once they cover the entire
space I will use a big capital R letter
for this bigger register so this called
the covering radius
so you can think of it in terms of
functions as follows so the packing
radius is a radius that guarantees that
they given any target there will be at
most one solution to the CVP there will
be zero point if you are too far or one
solution if you are close enough ever
you cannot have more than one point in
that border curve a radius is the radius
that guarantees always the existence of
at least one solution but possibly more
than one typically it will be more than
one lattice point within these largest
radius
and this is a problem that also comes up
in other areas for example so the
bounded distance decoding is what you
would naturally use in the context of
information transmission when you want
to send a message so these the problem
comes up in vector quantization you have
some point in space and you want to map
it to a point from a discrete set from a
lattice with small distortion and the
colony radius is precisely the best
upper bound that you can put on the
distortion no matter which point in
space you want to round so no matter
what point is given to you you can
always approximate it with an with a
lattice point within distance a big
arrow from it so through distance
decoding is a CVP assuming that so it's
not really CVP you're not required to
find the closest lattice pointer to the
target so it doesn't have to be closest
but you are taking an error a distance
error which is the worse possible
distance instead of a comparator instead
of using the distance of the actual
target you maximize overall over all
possible targets the distance between
the lattice point and the target of
course here you are also minimizing over
the lattice point and maximizing over
the target and you are trying to find
the solution within this absolute bound
that says you always find a solution now
somehow these two problems correspond
precisely to the SI s correspond to
absolute distance decoding and in fact
it can be seen as an average case
version of absolute distance recording
and the lwe problem is an average case
version of the bounded distance decoder
so these two problems seems to capture
Sonam the two pluses of applications
that you can build from sis and lwe one
is basing cryptography on the harness of
bounded distance decoding and the other
one is built-in functions out of this
absolute distance the God in them so a
natural question at this point is how do
these prongs relate to each other can
you show a connection between ADB and
ability and interestingly we'll see that
I'll show you that it is possible to
reduce one to the other one of them is
easier one of them is Harbor and as you
can expect the easier one is the one
that gives more applications because
assuming the DEP remains harder is a
stronger assumption it's an easier
problem you still as unit is harder and
you will be able to do much more with it
so the other one is a potentially harder
problem assuming it is hard is a weaker
assumption and you will get a
correspondingly weaker class of
applications so and in fact it is
possible to give reductions so in that
if you can solve the absolute distance
decoding in any lattice then you can
also solve that bounded distance
decoding in any lattice up to some small
change in the approximation factor you
can always make these problems
quantitatively easier or harder by
adjusting the radius if you make the
radius in the Banri distance decoding
even smaller than lambda one over to say
lambda 1 over 10 or lambda 1 over log n
some function of the dimension you can
make it easier and easier saying it oh
you are even closer to the lattice point
but as far as we know as long as you are
not too far away from lambda 1 this
seems to be a hard problem and similarly
here you can take you can get an easier
problem by using a radius which is a
little bit bigger than the covariant
radius so and so if you allow some
slackness in the exact value of the
to rowdy then it is possible to reduce
one problem to the other one and what
about the other direction so in the
other direction it is also possible to
give a reduction but the only known way
to give a reduction from the bounded
distance decoding to absolute distance
decoding involves quantum computation
and I think is one of the most puzzling
things in the complexity of lattice
cryptography because it also raises a
number of interesting questions of the
form is this really needed or is there a
way to do the reduction classically and
assume we live in a world where the you
only have this problem so all your in or
all you are allowed to do is that to use
this SAS problem and then you can ask oh
can I build the quant can I build public
key cryptography can build private key
cryptography in the answer to private
key cryptography is yes you can build
the symmetric encryption you can build
the hash functions and so on while
building public key cryptography somehow
requires that the problem should be hard
and not only by with play class with
classical computers but you need that
this is a quantum step to build it to
build a public key cryptography so do
you need so maybe there is something
deeper going on there and yes you can
base public key cryptography on si yes
under quantum reductions but you can
only bathe the private key cryptography
for never from si yes using classic
reductions so looking at these problems
in this perspective I think is something
that Mesa now also providing the end a
better understanding of the latus
problems themselves
so what I want to do in the rest of the
talk is to sketch how the two reductions
work it will be a sketch I will not
provide the full details but so the
reductions are a sufficiently si
imple that i think you can get a pretty
good idea of how they work and so there
is this will be the rest of the talks a
little bit more technical I will still
illustrate the reduction essentially by
drawing pictures rather than writing
mathematical formulas even the quantum
one so there will be some quantum
pictures but it will be my best yeah
I'll just different colors of a
superposition so maybe and we'll see
what we can do okay
so oh one last important question before
we move it to the technical part is
worried about SVP in CBP we do not know
how to build a cryptography from those
problems in fact some of these prawns
are are known to be equivalent up to
some small change in the approximation
factor for example the bounded distance
decoding is roughly equivalent under
classic reductions efficient reductions
to the gap is VP which means solve the
shortest vector problem about without
finding the shortest vector so gap is VP
asks to find just this quantity you want
to approximate the value of lambda one
without finding the shortest vector so
we don't know how to find the value of
lambda one without finding the shortest
vector so algorithmically they don't
seem to be much different but from a
complexity point of view approximating
the length of lambda one is reducible in
both directions to the complexity of the
bounded distance decoding so so this a
bit this is not quite missile
satisfactory you may want to assume that
finding the surest vector is hard and
not just finding the light so assuming
it even finding the length is hard that
seems a much stronger assumption you can
get good upper bounds on the length for
example using minkowski's theorem and
there is also a special version of the
shortest vector problem called the
unique shortest vector problem which is
finding the shortest vector in an artist
when it is unusually short much shorter
than any other vector in the lattice
that's called the
unique shortest vector problem and it is
also in this category all these problems
can be related via reductions a classic
polynomial time reduction so these in a
work of myself with Vadim Luba shainsky
I think 2009 I believe that showing that
those three problems fall in the same
category on the other hand the absolute
distance decoding can be shown to be
equivalent to the shortest independent
vector problem which is a variant of SVP
that has to find not just one but n
linearly independent vectors potentially
larger than lambda one and I will not
get into the exact definition of the
problem but it is somewhere in between
now all these problems can be classified
into what gives symmetric cryptography
or public key cryptography under classic
reductions
well SVP and CVP is are there on their
own we don't know how to build a
cryptography from them so an interesting
open problem that I wanted the to your
pause here to this group of people is uh
perhaps the quantum reductions can also
help in the direction is it possible to
give a quantum reduction from the SVP or
sivb problem through s IV p or ad d so
the same way that so if we so we can
draw a picture of these problems as
divided into classes so we have in
[Music]
in these bottom in this simplest class
we have a bounded distance decoding gap
as VP us VP they all relate to each
other and here we have the shortest
independent vector problem and the
absolute distance decoding problem and
we know how to give reductions in one
direction classically and we know how to
be reduction in the other direction but
using the power of quantum computers and
here at about so these are the classes
from which we can build cryptography and
SVP and CVP up to approximation factors
that can be shown to be essentially
equivalent with each other
and we know how to give the classic
reductions from the top problems to the
bottom and that question it is openness
I use a different color for this one in
green so an interesting question is if
it is possible to give a reduction that
allows you to use these problems to
construct the cryptographic applications
if the quantum can can be used I mean
given a classical reduction would be
even more interesting but that's
something that I think has received a
certain amount of attention at least I
tried for a while and I couldn't and I
mean you can also try better luck no
sería no no I didn't want to discourage
anybody by looking for classic reduction
but perhaps the quantum reduction can
give you you know one more weapon to
attack this problem so see if it's
possible to do it is interesting so the
other the other open questions of course
are if it's possible to do this without
the power
of quantum reductions but I guess most
people here like quantum so yeah yes so
then for them last part you can be done
deterministically so deterministic but
they are often reductions that make
several calls to the target problem they
are not you know many one reductions and
also they all lose something in the
approximation factor typically you lose
a square root of any factor for some of
these problems you can give reduction
with a smaller loss but square to square
root of n is quite common and whether it
is possible to give a stronger reduction
with a smaller loss in the approximation
factor so that's a very interesting very
interesting question to establish tyre
connections between the problems for
some of them the reduction is very tight
for example between this tool BBB and
usvp so the first reduction in my paper
with Vadim was showing that they are
equivalent up to a factor two in
approximation so what you lose in
approximation is very small and then at
least so the mean lower the diss factor
with by N one correct so he lowered it
to square root of two and I think more
it should be possible to reduce it to
one to get a reduction between the
problems it doesn't lose anything in the
approximation factor but is yeah so
that's that's open so randomness is
useful in some reductions so if you want
to give a many one reduction there are
randomized reductions that make a single
call but if you are allowed to make
multiple calls I think everything can be
done deterministically I mean no not not
a quantum rather I mean the quantum
reductions I guess they all involve some
some form of randomness as you would
expect that ok so let's get it to the
reductions so we'll only talk about the
BDD Nadd at this point so let me remove
the list of problems
and I assume everybody wants to see the
easier reduction first okay so what
we'll start with is a reduction showing
that if you can solve the absolute
distance decoding on any lattice then
you can solve the bounded distance
decoding in any note that not
necessarily the same lattice so we'll
use these two problems on different
lattices and use this freedom that you
can change the lattice to connect the
two the two problems so the idea is the
following so this is our starting point
so we are given a bounded distance
decoding instance which consists of a
lattice and a target point T which is
close to the lattice is within these
packing radius
just a special case because this one
will always return that unique solution
which is guaranteed to be the closest
lattice point in the absolute distance
decoding you just need to find a point
within the colony radius which is not
necessarily the lattice point closest to
the target I may give you a solution
which is not optimal
so if you add of course if in that case
it just if you just increase the radius
so there would be the closest vector
problem and yes so these are both
special versions of the closest vector
for a good pointer so so there are both
special versions of the closest vector
problem but what makes this one another
special case of the other one is because
by increasing the radius we are also
increasing the set of valid the
solutions of solutions which are active
of the lattice points which are accepted
as the solving it so it may be a non
optimal solution so so geometrically
there is another way to describe the two
problems by considering the Voronoi cell
of the lattice the Voronoi cell of a
lattice is the set of points which are
closest to the lattice point then to any
other point and there is the way these
two prongs right to the verona cell is
that the bounded distance decoding is
you know what that it with a green but
here
so bounded distance decoding is the
coding within a sphere which is inside
every cell while absolute distance
decoding is so the covariance is
precisely the radius of the smallest
ball that contain the Voronoi cell and I
mean you can also put these equivalently
around the target and then ask is there
a point within this ball or within this
region and the closest vector problem
correspond to the Voronoi cell so
Voronoi cell is always the solution is
unique and it is the closest lattice
point the green ball is the closest
lattice point by does not always exist
if I give you something here then there
will be no point within the green ball
distance while in the absolute distance
decoding I may give you a point which is
outside the Voronoi cell and that's
still within the covering register so
it's considered a valid solution so okay
so we are giving this target T we want
to find a point the closest to it if we
simply make a call to the absolute
distance decoding we consider a bigger
ball and we may be given a lattice point
which is not really the closest we may
get something which is not what we want
so what can we do so I mean you can try
to work with approximations I don't know
how to make it work but it's certainly
something that it's probably most
intuitive thing to try Oh first they try
to find something that is not too far
and then try to go from there to there
okay it's a good idea I don't know how
to make it work so what I know how to
make it work is using lattice duality
and you don't know what they do a
lattice is you can watch some of the
videos from the bootcamp
we don't really need the definition for
to illustrate the idea for the purpose
of this talk all you need to know is
that every lattice as a corresponding
dual lattice
which lives in a different space I think
of it as something that is not
geometrically connected to to data but
the lattice the points in the dual
lattice they correspond to way of
partition the primal lattice into layers
so technically the definition of law I
do a lot this is the set of the points
in a maybe used to light so a so this is
the origin this is a vector V in the
dual lattice so technically the
definition of dual lattice is the set of
vectors in Euclidean space that have the
integer scalar product with all the
points in the lattice so so texts so we
know that to be scalar product with a
lattice is always an integer and this is
our lattice l now since this color
product is always an integer so
depending on which integer you get so
this vector V induces a partition of the
lattice in two layers all the lattice
points that have scalar product zero all
the points of the scalar product one all
the points of the scalar product two and
so on so it is a way to partition your
your lattice into layers and it is easy
to see that the longer is this vector V
the closer will be the layers with each
other similarly if the vector V is very
short then the distance between the
layers will be large in fact the
distance is exactly 1 over the length of
this vector now this is the idea so a
lattice a lattice L and it's dual and
star are related by the fact that if one
lattice has a short minimum distance if
lambda 1 is smaller then this lattice
will have large minimum distances it's
not lambda 1 the quantity you consider
here is the
one corresponding to the SI VV problem
you can find n linearly independent
short vectors
similarly if lambda 1 is smaller in the
lattice sorry we want it to be larger so
intuitively since we want to solve the
bounded distance decoding no we are
thinking of this lattice has been a good
lattice for encoding so it is a large
alot is with a large minimum distance so
think of starting from lattice with
Buddha coding property and large minimum
distance so here in the dual lattice
will have a small lambda n which means
you can find n linearly independent
short vectors and these vectors can be
found using an EDD Oracle and they can
be found as follows
you start from just pick any point in
space which is far from the origin is a
distance from the origin at least R the
colony radius so R or R plus Epsilon
just a tiny bit more than error and
notice this that is the covering radius
of the lattice which is roughly
equivalent to this lambda and lambda n
star so the if you want you can
disregard that is a shortest in Si VP
problem and just think of it in terms of
a covering radius so you know that these
so you you get that far and you know
that you are guaranteed to find a
lattice point within this ball and this
lattice point will be nonzero because
you went to R plus epsilon away from 0
so that will give you a first lattice
point here so once you find that this
lattice point using your EDD Oracle you
can do the same but this time you pick a
point a distance R plus epsilon from the
linear span of what you have already
found so you take something orthogonal
to it and then you try to find a lattice
point in
sigh this bowl and since since since
this bowl is this joint from this either
plane you will get a vector which is
linearly independent from the first one
I mean that's where you stop in two
dimensions you have two linearly
independent vectors and these two
linearly independent vectors are shorted
you can find them using the ad D Oracle
and each one of them induces a partition
of the lattice into layers which are far
apart from each other so if I give you a
target T you can first find the layer
from the first classification that is
closest to the target then you take your
next target let's say this one which
gives another way to partition the
lattice in two layers and you find what
is the layer from this other arrangement
that is closest to the target in general
in n dimensions you will find the N I
per planes which are closer to the
target and the intersection of this and
hyper planes will be a single point
which is precisely the point closer to T
and this way you found the solution to
the BDD problem so in this last ya mean
it I want to illustrate how the other
direction work so I'll give a
superposition of all the steps of the
proof so the idea again is to use the
duality but we use it in a quite
different way and the
so this is our lattice or dual if you
take the dual of the dual you get back
to the original lattice so so which one
is primal which one is dual dozen
doesn't really doesn't really matter
let's say that we want to move in this
direction this time so here we have a
lattice where we want to solve that
bounded this then no we want to solve
the absolute distance decoding problem
in this lattice we want to find the
short vectors in this lattice and all I
tell you is o if you want I can solve
bounded distance decoding instances for
you so what you do is to say let's do
this let's take the dual lattice and
let's see what we can do here and what
we can do here is the following you can
first build
a random point in space with so you can
pick a random target here in space T
with Gaussian probability so take a
Gaussian so often in cryptography you
choose this point at random here instead
of taking this point with random
probability what we do is to take a
random a superposition of all these
points we take a Gaussian a quantum
Gaussian so we take a superposition with
Gaussian probability of our vector T now
as you probably know the Fourier
transform of a Gaussian is a Gaussian so
if you saw here using real numbers which
you can avoid by using a fine grid so
this requires infinitely many qubits so
but that's not a hard part of the probe
you can you can restrict it to a
discrete grid so assuming you do that so
what happen if you take so this is a
quantum machine and what happen if you
take the quantum Fourier transform the
Fourier transform of a Gaussian is a
Gaussian so what you get is exactly the
same thing here you will get a quantum
Gaussian in the dual lattice now that's
not useful you could have built that to
start with so what you do then is the
following instead of applying the
quantum Fourier transform on the
original quantum Gaussian superposition
first you take this point and you reduce
it modulo the lattice
so that means that you only look at a
displacement of the point inside the
fundamental region of your lattice now
in quanta you know you can only perform
a reversible transformations but that's
exactly where bility helps so this
Gaussian is small enough that if you
reduce in maduro the lattice you can
recover the original point to use in BDD
okay so this allows you to perform this
operation on the quantum to super first
visions of the Gaussian set now instead
of taking a Fourier transform of the
Gaussian in RN you take the quantum
Fourier transform of a Gaussian in this
the fundamental region and if you know a
bit about topological groups so this one
is a compact group and the duality
theory for groups and free transform
says that when you take so if you have
an arbitrary group you can still take
the quantum Fourier transform and you
will get a Gaussian in the dual group
but the dual of a compact group is a
discrete group which is precisely the
dual lattice so what you will get over
there is a Gaussian but restricted to
the lattice points rather than a
Gaussian in RN at which point you just
need to look at it you observe it and
this Gaussian superposition restricted
to the lattice will collapse to a point
from the lattice chosen with a
probability distribution which is
Gaussian so it is likely to be close to
the close to the origin and since it is
random if you repeat it n times you will
get n linearly independent points from
this gaussians and then once you have
those points you can solve ad d-- just
by just by rounding so that's how the
quantum comes in and it is not known how
any other method to make use of a
bounded distance decoding Oracle so the
fact that so that's all we can do using
BDD I think is a quite an interesting
question
in the area of the complexity of lattice
problems especially as it relates to
lattice cryptography okay so thank you
for your attention this reduction okay
so these something that appeared first
implicitly in other dragons paper were
showing the harness of the over the lwe
problem so rag of 2005 and that's
implicit and it is about worst case
problems and then there is also a paper
by stella Stainfield ex Anika in Tagawa
showing a similar reduction between the
other case problems the same idea can
also be used to show that if you can
solve lwe then you can solve the quantum
yes I yes and that's in this SSD X paper
from adding 2009
[Applause]